birth America indiana hawkins a growing  patriotic community and a shining  example of the american dream today  Hawkins is taking another step into the  future with the brand-new star court  mall families friends and of course  teenagers and come together to shop hang  out  and enjoy with retail options for every  member of the family including the gap  Walden and Sam Goody star court wall has  it all and don't forget a  state-of-the-art food court just  escalator right away  featuring America's favorite place to  cool down scoops a whole ice cream shop  [Music]  ahoy star court ball is one of the  finest shopping facilities in America  and beyond so come on down and remember  star court mall has it all star court is  an all-american subsidiary of star Kord  industries and international enterprise  you